there are activities that we can do that
will give us healthy sustained increases
in dopamine both the Peaks when they
happen and to maintain or even increase
our Baseline levels of dopamine so how
do we do that what are some of these
activities in recent years there's been
a trend toward more people doing
so-called cold exposure getting into
cold showers taking ice baths first of
all upon getting into cold water the
changes in Adrenaline and noradrenaline
epinephrine and norepinephrine were
immediate and fast and these were huge
increases so that's the getting into the
cold water that everybody experiences
these huge increases in Adrenaline but
then what was interesting is they
observe increase in dopamine from a cold
water exposure of this kind was
comparable to what one sees from cocaine
except in this case it wasn't a rise and
crash it was actually a sustained rise
in dopamine that took a very long time
up to three hours to come back down to
Baseline which is really remarkable